foreign
and welcome to today's webinar emerging
solutions for non-invasive cancer
monitoring I'm antonina Salcido of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by new probe to learn more please visit
newprobe.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Nick gallerani scientific Affairs at new
Pro
Nick you may now begin your presentation
great thank you
good morning everyone and thank you for
joining today's session uh and thank you
to lab Roots also for organizing this
event my name is Nick elurani and I work
in scientific Affairs at new probe today
what I'm going to be talking about is a
new probe and a technology that we've
developed called blocker displacement
amplification or BDA which we have begun
to apply to non-invasive cancer
monitoring research
so there are three main objectives for
today's talk uh one is to briefly go
over the current state advantages and
limitations of non-invasive liquid
biopsies in oncology applications
the second goal is to introduce the BDA
technology and highlight some of those
applications that we've begun in
non-invasive longitudinal monitoring
and then lastly I want to go over the
new probe ourselves and highlight some
of the ways that these Technologies can
be accessed by working with new
Okay so
as you may be aware the emergence of
liquid biopsy has enabled many
non-invasive testing options for cancer
patients including recurrence monitoring
non-invasive tumor profiling and
non-invasive therapy selection as well
as early cancer screening
liquid biopsy can refer to a range of
different types of tests but for new
probe we're mainly developing Next
Generation sequencing based tests for
cell-free DNA analysis as well as
peripheral blood analysis in the case of
heme cancers such as acute myeloid
leukemia
and with test modalities like NGS we can
extract broad genetic information which
may give the patient insights into
things like disease prognosis which
drugs are likely to be effective and
which ones we might expect to see
resistance too
now one of the central challenges in
liquid biopsy is that the tumor
associate analytes themselves are quite
rare and in context such as monitoring
or early detection and cell-free DNA
that originates from the cancer may only
constitute 0.01 or even less of the
total fraction of cell-free DNA
and just to broaden the scope of this
problem a little bit for both solid
tumor and heme malignancy monitoring
applications we see similar Rarity
problems
in mrd we want to be able to detect
signs of recurrence earlier so that we
can also ACT earlier on the cancer
but if a patient is responding very well
the amounts of cancer Associated
analytes are going to decline
significantly to the point where they
may be undetectable by most methods even
if they have Trace remnants of disease
or small drug resistance clones which
may eventually Drive relapse
while there are certain error correcting
NGS methods that have been employed that
are able to detect mutations at very low
levels these may be costly to implement
and they also May potentially show poor
performance at single low side
so beyond just low concentration of
analytes and cost sensitivity balance a
lot of different challenges exist in the
liquid biopsy space before liquid
biopsy's potential can really be fully
realized
I think some of these can be considered
biological in nature some of these
include concordance between tissue and
liquid samples as well as detection of
other important genetic biomarkers such
as copy number variation
but there are also a lot of challenges
on the clinical implementation side some
of these include achieving that balance
of sensitivity and costs that I talked
about
standardizing pre-analytical variables
and then also what to do with all of the
results especially for some of these
ultra low frequency events
at the current stage that new probe is
at we're not we're not really addressing
all of these issues but
um you know as a company that is
interested in this space I think it's
important for everyone in this space to
understand the bigger picture of what
we're looking at
so like I said new probe is a is a
fairly small company that can only focus
on so many things so today what we
really want to focus on is the issue of
low concentration of analytes and
achieving this cost sensitivity balance
uh and so I'll introduce this technology
which is based on our BDA technology
called quantitative blocker displacement
amplification this was first featured in
a pub and 2021 publication in nature
Communications and this is available
through Open Access so nature
Communications website
Okay so
this technology blocker displacement
amplification is a rare allele
enrichment method which enables us to
selectively enrich mutant alleles while
suppressing amplification of wild-type
alleles during PCR
this enables us to sensitively detect
mutations at single loci below 0.01 vaf
and this method is flexible and can be
incorporated into a wide range of
modalities including qpcr and NGS From
newport's perspective but we've also
recently engaged in development of
digital PCR assays we recently announced
a deal with bio rad to incorporate BDA
technology into digital PCR assays so on
the horizon we can look out for new
highly sensitive digital PCR assays from
biorad that contain the same technology
so the way that the way that this
technology works is through a
competitive hybridization reaction
between a non-extensible oligonucleotide
called a blocker and an extensible
primer
the blocker is designed to be
complementary to a known DNA sequence in
this case the wild type template
well the primer is designed to have a
region of overlap between the between
the um
the blocker and primer
and so
so basically this this region of overlap
creates creates competition between
primer and blocker when a variant is
present within a 12 to 30 nucleotide
region uh which we call the
amplification window at the three prime
end of the blocker it creates a mismatch
this mismatch shifts the favorability of
primer binding such that the primer now
out competes the blocker for access to
the binding site at that region of
overlap
and over multiple Cycles at PCR we can
achieve significant enrichment of
variance while suppressing amplification
of the known sequence
and so over many rounds of PCR this can
lead to over a thousand-fold
magnification of those those variants
now several of these methods for rare
allele enrichment have been described in
literature but I think what
differentiates the BDA amplification
approach is really its scalability so
BDA enrichment can efficiently occur
over a broader range of temperatures
compared to some of these other methods
that have been described such as in this
case LNA clamp PCR
and this has enabled us to really scale
up BDA assays to NGS approaches allowing
low depth sequencing analysis of low vaf
mutations
now in order to effectively scale up to
these NGS
NGS levels we have also Incorporated
we've made a modification of the core
BDA technology and Incorporated unique
molecular identifiers into our BDA
approach and this is really what
quantitative blocker displacement
amplification is it's bdas plus umis to
improve quantitation and correct for
polymerase error that occurs during PCR
so experimentally uh in order to
demonstrate this benefit of reducing uh
the vile type read fraction
what we did first was we created a set
of reference materials which consisted
of wild type DNA that was mixed with
nine different synthetic DNA G blocks
each containing a different SNB or indel
at roughly one percent vaf
using a standard NGS approach without
enrichment 88 percent of the NGS reads
were wild type whereas with qvda
only about two percent of the total
reads were wild type we did observe a
small fraction of unexpected variance
likely introduced by polymerase errors
but because we have this Umi filtering
um and bioinformatics pipeline we're
able to effectively filter these false
variants out
so we then constructed a 20 Gene NGS
panel capable of detecting over 450 smvs
and indels in hot spots related to acute
wineline leukemia
and again using synthetic reference
material we compared qbda to NGS with
umis but without this enrichment and
even at vif levels below 0.01 percent
and in some cases well below 0.1 percent
we found that all the mutations were
detected using the qbda approach and in
terms of quantitation uh over 80 percent
of the mutations were within twofold of
the VF determined without enrichment
showing that although we are modifying
the vaf percentage of the sample we are
able to accurately quantitate the vaf in
in our library
and importantly uh because because we
are using this wild type suppressing
technology we were able to detect these
mutations using only four million
sequencing reads total
a significant reduction compared to deep
sequencing approaches
so next we applied the qbda AML panel to
a handful of retrospective clinical
samples collected from five ml patients
at time of diagnosis and also during
complete remission
uh so using qbda we were able to
identify a mutation in the npm1 gene at
.0052 vaf uh inpatient one and this was
missed by both flow cytometry and
conventional NGS this patient later
passed away due to relapse of the
disease
and in a second patient qbda as well as
other NGS did not observe npm1 mutations
in this case actually flow cytometry did
report mrd positivity NGS results at
later time points during relapse
confirmed the lack of npm1 mutations but
did detect de novo mutations in KDM 6A
and phf6 which we think suggests of this
patient experience clonal evolution
uh driving their driving their relapse
so while qbda did not detect these
mutations uh this appears to this this
likely is due to the makeup of the
initial prototype panel uh rather than
the technology itself our npm1 results
were consistently concordant with these
other NGS methods but we didn't have KDM
6A or phf6 on the panel but I think
you know the fact that we're in in at
least one patient we were able to
observe this npm1 mutation uh at .0052
vaf that was missed earlier and appeared
later on conventional NGS
um
suggests that this technology is very
promising for monitoring of residual
disease amplifications in acute myeloid
leukemia but I think the content itself
for the panel may need to be expanded to
function as a clinical uh mrd assay
and I do want to also be clear that all
of these samples here were used
retrospectively currently all of our
products are for research use only
so with that in mind we are actually a
project partner for an fnah biomarkers
Consortium project to establish new
methods for detecting disease in AML
uh we don't have anything specific to
share Beyond mentioning that we were
working on this at this time but we're
hoping to have some updates in the
coming months
now with that said uh in the in the
publication itself we do actually
demonstrate our ability to expand out
and broaden our panel coverage
so
in that paper we built a pan cancer
panel that covered 61 genes and over 6
300 mutations from the cosmic database
and this consisted of 360 applicants
split across two tubes and in the paper
we we test a variety of different uh
clinical sample types that were all
commercially obtained including cell
free DNA ffpe fresh frozen tumor tissue
um and also pbmc samples and and we show
that we're compatible with all of these
different types of samples but what I
wanted to highlight was really data that
was kind of similar to what I showed
earlier with the AML panel
um so using a number of contrived
samples that we prepared similar to what
we what I showed earlier we demonstrated
our ability to detect and quantify
mutations below point one percent vaf
and in some cases 0.01 the AF and showed
good concordance with a standard U NGS
method uh with with umis but without
enrichment
suggesting that we can really
significantly expand the content of our
panels while maintaining the performance
and the benefits of BDA
okay so just to highlight just to
summarize everything that I've gone
through today uh quantitative blocker
displacement amplification or qbda
enables highly multiplexed enrichment of
rare sequences such as smvs and indels
and detects and quantifies mutations
below 0.01 vaf using both tissue or
liquid samples
qbda reduces the relative fraction of
wild-type reads in NGS which enables
High sensitivity mutation sequencing
with reduced sequencing requirements
this potentially translates to better
cost efficiency as well as turnaround
time
uh qbda has been applied to clinical
longitudinal blood samples from AML
patients and we think that this has
great potential for longitudinal
monitoring than other liquid biopsy
applications
we were looking to further establish
collaborations that may be able to
further demonstrate some of these
benefits some potential benefits
okay so I wanted to next shift gears a
little bit and talk about new probe the
company
as as we are a startup and people may
not be fully aware of how how our
company works and how you can actually
work with new probe and access some of
these technologies that I've been
describing
so new probe is a developer of molecular
Technologies mainly focused in PCR and
NGS for improved detection of nucleic
acid biomarkers
so
new probe has its origins in Academia we
are a spin-out lab from using
Technologies from both Rice University
and the Weiss Institute at Harvard
with these Tech we've continued that
Spirit of technological innovation and
greatly expanded upon the original
technologies that our company started
with and developed a for a broader range
of Technologies designed to detect
different types of nucleic acid
biomarkers so the one that I talked
about today blocker displacement
amplification
uh is is designed for smbs and indels
but we're also working on
um you know other types of biomarkers
such as gene expression uh Gene fusions
as well as copy number variation
and so I wasn't planning I wasn't really
planning to go over these other
Technologies but just briefly in case
these are of Interest we have had some
other recent Publications also available
in nature Communications highlighting
some of these other Technologies uh
briefly of the first one quantitative
amplicon sequencing this is an
amplicon-based NGS workflow for Ultra
sensitive detection of copy number
variation down to five percent single
copy change in her2
as well as mutations down to 0.1 percent
vaf using low sample input
we also have expertise in primary design
we had we had we recently published
another paper about one of our primary
design algorithms for design of Highly
Multiplex PCR primer sets that minimize
primer dimer formation
uh this allows us to efficiently design
new Multiplex PCR and NGS assays
okay so we have this broad range of
Technologies but how do people work with
new probe
so what we mainly do is we leverage this
portfolio of Technologies and
collaborate with companies in the
biopharmaceutical Life Science and
diagnostic spaces and also work with
researchers who may who may be able to
utilize these Technologies
the main things that we do are sample
testing using defined NGS and PCR assays
and we also provide custom assay
development services to support
translational research programs we are
aware that you know research each
individual case is often different and
requirements May differ for different
assets
and so we we are prepared to rapidly
um
uh yeah rapidly
rapidly develop new solutions for
different biomarkers which you may need
just to briefly cover the current
offering for sample testing so we have
three assays that utilize the
quantitative blocker displacement
amplification technology that I
described today
and the first being
the AML mrd assay which I which I showed
data for earlier
and then also the pan cancer NGS assay
we also have an assay designed for
melanoma targets
on the qac side of things we have a her2
cnv assay and then we also have
Solutions using RNA for gene expression
as well as a number of different qpcr
assays
and all of these assays in a research
use only format are available
immediately for testing
I do want to describe our how our custom
assay development program works
so we follow a consultative model where
our team meets with your team and
discusses the specific problem that that
your team may be having with with
certain biomarker detection
and we come up with a solution that
utilizes our our Technologies our family
of Technologies
generally we can deliver a custom NGS
assay of about 200 amplicons in about 14
weeks and this is generally targeted at
translational research programs but
you know if if this is of Interest feel
free to reach out
okay so that brings me to the end of
this talk so
non-invasive liquid biopsies are an
important and emerging field in oncology
testing
new probe is developing a wide range of
Technologies which may have features
that improve liquid biopsies such as a
quantitative blocker displacement
amplification technology which I
described
and these Technologies are currently
available to biopharma life science and
research through our sample testing and
customized development services
all right with that I just want to thank
everyone for joining and we can take any
questions
great thank you so much Nick very
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
now let's get started our first question
is how can you quantify the variant
allele frequency in the original sample
after BDA
yeah
so BDA can accurately quantify the
variant allele frequency of the original
sample uh but you're correct that BDA
also Alters the variant allele frequency
that we're measuring in the library
so this calculation is automatically
performed by our analysis software uh by
taking into account the input DNA amount
and you may Umi barcode and conversion
yield
and to accurately estimate input DNA we
also include internal positive controls
on the NGS panels that don't have
blockers that enable us to quantify
quantitate molecules at several
different loci in housekeeping genes
I also want to point out uh you know
since you know bioinformatics that can
sometimes be a bit of a black box I
think the most powerful piece of data
that we showed in this webinar is that
we highlighted some data from the
publication where we did actually
compare the the quantitation accuracy of
quantitative blocker displacement
amplification against
Umi NGS without enrichment and showed
good concordance between those two
methods showing that our method
um
in spite of altering the vaf
during enrichment we are able to
quantify the original vif with the
sample
thank you another question here has the
BDA technology been applied to other
biofluids specifically S A CSF
uh no not at this time that is something
that we would definitely be interested
in in trying uh because we think that
the same benefits that that we see in in
some in like blood or cell free DNA
should be applicable to salt and toes to
CSF as well but we just haven't been
able to actually
try that that would be an area of
interest for collaboration for us
yeah something we're very interested in
great thank you and the next question is
BDA available as a kit
uh yeah so currently we don't offer any
kitted products instead we offer ruo
sample testing services at our Houston r
d facility and that uses that menu of
predefined
um
predefined NGS assays and other qpcr
assays as well
yeah and you know like I also mentioned
another channel that BDA is accessible
or will be accessible uh will be through
biorad and their digital PCR assays
great thank you again Nick
free time today and your important
research
to thank lab roots and our sponsor new
probe for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further questions questions we do not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any one of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye